Binary trees are simply trees for
where parents have at most two children.
This means nodes can have zero,
one, or two children.
Those children might even be null,
but that's okay.
Let's see what search looks
like in a binary tree.
We could start off by using any
of the traversal algorithms to go
through the tree.
Because there's no real order to
the elements, I need to go through every
single element in the tree if the value
I'm looking for doesn't exist.
There are no cool tricks here, so
we're stuck with a linear time search.
A delete operation often starts out with
a search since you need to find the node
you want to delete.
If you're deleting a leaf,
you can simply delete it and move on.
However, if you delete an internal node,
you'll suddenly have a gap in the tree.
If the node you deleted only has one
child, you can actually just take it out
move the child up and
attach it to the old node's parent.
If you're trying to get rid of
a node that has two children,
you have a few options.
You could promote the child
up just like you did before.
Of course, it can't always be that easy.
What if both children
also have two children?
In the worst case,
you'll need to keep traversing down
the sub tree until you hit a leaf.
Since there is no real
order requirement here,
you can just put the leaf where your
deleted node was without a problem.
Since there's a search involved and
some additional work to shift around
the elements after deletion,
the run time is linear.